so whilst we seem to be on a topic of
Greek mythology's most commonly asked
questions another one that I see quite
often relates to the differences between
a Titan and a God so is a Titan a God or
are they completely different entities
entirely I've seen people make the
argument that Titans and gods are not
the same
instead Titans that he's giant beings
born with powers that symbolise the
creation of our world and as an
extension of ourselves now some of that
statement may in fact be true but
everything we see in Greek mythology
points towards Titans and gods being
classified as very similar if not the
exact same type of entity my videos on
Titans are all labeled Titan goddess or
Titan God and that's because to me the
word Titan describes what type of God
they are and what generation they came
from Greek mythology at its core can be
broken down into three separate
generations the primordial deities such
as Uranus and Gaia who are the oldest
generation and who physically make up
the earth these deities are often seen
as personifications such as the earth
the sky and the sea but at times they
are also depicted as being their own
physical being the primordial deities
then gave birth to the Titans who are
physical beings but who also represent
abstract places and ideas
the Titans then of course had their own
children but these children are somewhat
divided we have the children of Cronus
and Rhea who would be known as the
Olympians or the Olympic deities Zeus
and his brothers and sisters we also
have the children that belonged to the
rest of the Titans who would be
classified as the second generation of
Titan these two combined made up the
vast majority of the third generation so
it seems like a fairly simple concept to
follow three generations of gods and
goddesses with each one representing
slightly different things but they are
all still gods and goddesses so where
does this disconnect come from that
claims a Titan can be born from a god
give birth to a god and yet somehow
still not be considered a god honestly
I'm not entirely sure but the first ever
video I made on the God of War franchise
did give me a slight insight into why
some people may have come to this
conclusion in that specific video I
called Gaia a goddess when the amount of
responses I received from people telling
me guy isn't a goddess she's a Titan was
definitely quite confusing at the time
obviously God of War doesn't do a great
job when it comes to representing and
explaining the Titans and the primordial
deities we
at times they distinguish between God
and Titan rather than tighten and
Olympian so it's understandable for
there to be some amount of confusion the
Titans are also depicted as being
monstrous beings and I think size may be
one of the key reasons that people in
general think Titans and gods are not
the same the primal due date is
representing the earth can be seen as
colossal in size and as a result the
Titans most likely would have been so as
well but it's important to know that for
all of them to fit on the earth together
the Titans would have have to have been
significantly smaller most of the
second-generation Titans and the
Olympians are never described as being
enormous or colossal in size but we do
know that they were capable of
manipulating their own physical form we
see this some numerous occasions in many
stories so it isn't then a huge stretch
of the imagination to believe that they
were capable of change in their own
science whenever it best suited them
there are some things in Greek mythology
however that we do know one of those
being that the only thing that can
create a god or goddess is another god
or goddess and of course there will
always be some exceptions to this rule
and some of you may be thinking well
what about a nymph or a demigod what
demigods are only half God and it is
true that nymphs give birth to many of
the gods that we know but nymphs are
still considered minor deities even if
we use the example of Dionysus the only
God to be born from a mortal it still
really isn't the case because Dionysus
was taken out of his dead mother and
then sewn into Zeus's thigh from which
he would later be born we do see gods
and goddesses however create and give
birth to other entities Gaia gave birth
to the Giants the Hecate on queries in
the Cyclopes but we never really
consider them deities Pegasus came from
Medusa and Poseidon it's not uncommon to
see a day to give birth to something
that isn't a god or goddess but the only
thing that can give birth to a deity is
another deity we can even simply look at
the Titans children the Olympians were
born around the same time as many of the
second-generation Titans so why are they
different why do we distinguish between
Olympian and second generation Titan
despite them being born at the same time
in the same generation and from the same
place the answer is nothing nothing
physical at least the only reason the
Olympians have a different title
is because they overthrew the ruling
class and they marked a new era the rule
of the third generation so it seems
rather strange to classify the Olympians
as gods but then say the second
generation Titans who were born at the
same
I'm from the same place or something
different entirely so the summarize
launched the question is a Titan a god
yes Titans are just simply an older
generation of deities elder gods I guess
we can call them the terms primordial
Titan an Olympian simply helped to
identify what generation at 80 belongs
to but do I think all three generations
were the same type of deity no I think
each generation was unique in its own
way and their children slowly evolved
over time marking the progress and
advancement of civilization hopefully
that clears up any confusion that you
may have had but if you have any more
questions or thoughts on topic then
please let me know in the comments below
as always I've been your host mythology
and fiction explain